[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully
it is the bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast
call 800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835-6747
now here's your host from amazing facts
international pastor doug batchelor hi
listening friends welcome to amazing
facts bible answers live would you like
to hear an amazing fact
back in 1794 at the request of congress
engraver robert scott began preparing
designs for the united states first
silver dollar
it portrayed liberty as the head of a
woman with free flowing hair
and on the back was a small eagle on a
rock surrounded by a wreath
when the first die was complete they
stamped a few copper sample coins as
prototypes to examine their work
they decided to add a circle of stars
around the head and a few other artistic
changes so those first copper sample
coins were tossed aside
82 years later someone excavated one of
those first test coins from the site of
the philadelphia mint
even though it was beaten at a little
corroded they recognized its historic
value and held on to it
in the following years that rare copper
coin changed hands among collectors
seven times
then in april 2021 it sold in an auction
for a whopping eight hundred and forty
thousand dollars over twice the
estimated amount
talk about inflation can you imagine
that pastor ross it wasn't even a real
silver dollar it was a copper sample of
a silver dollar but it was our first
currency
you have a copper coin selling for more
than eight hundred thousand dollars just
look at the value of that obviously the
coin was far more value than the
substance that it was made out of yeah
it's like the weight of three pennies
was in there
three quarters of a million dollars for
the coin
yeah well you know pastor
just listening to that fact reminds me
that here you have a coin that is more
valuable than obviously the materials
that it's made from
and you look at the gospel account here
you have god giving his son jesus to
purchase us to buy us back to redeem us
and what is our value yeah and yet he
felt that we were so valuable that it
was willing to give his son so great you
know they say that if you want to know
the value of something it's what someone
will pay that's right and so our value
is estimated by what the father was
willing to pay
it reminds me of a parable that you find
in matthew chapter 13 verse 44
again the kingdom of heaven is like a
treasure hidden in a field which a man
found and hid and for joy over it he
goes and sells all that he has and buys
that field
again the kingdom of heaven is like a
merchant seeking beautiful pearls who
when he has found one of great price he
went and sold all that he had and he
bought it and the lord is saying that
of course we're of great value in that
he gave his life for us but the gospel
the plan of salvation is worth more than
anything in this world we need to be
willing to
sell everything so to speak to get a
hold of that eternal life that jesus
offers you know pastor we got a book
that talks about god's wonderful grace
and it's called the riches of his grace
and it talks about god's love and yeah
it's behind it's beyond understanding or
comprehension that god would love us
just
mere mortals to the point of being
willing to give his son so that we could
live with him forever it's an incredible
story i mean it's true it's true story
but it's an incredible story of course
riches of his grace is our free offer
for today we'll be happy to send this to
anyone who calls an ass all you have to
do is call the number it's on the screen
800-835-6747 you're going to ask for the
book it's called riches of his grace
we'll be happy to send that to anyone in
north america now i know pastor we've
got friends who are listening outside of
north america if you'd like to read the
book just go to the amazing facts
website just amazingfacts.org
and you'll be able to read the book
there online and it might be a good time
for us to welcome those who are joining
us on amazing facts tv also those who
are watching on good news tv and those
who are live streaming across the
country we have folks watching on the
youtube channel on the doug bachelor
facebook page also the amazing facts
facebook page so if you want to
participate and see what's happening
here in the studio you can just go to
one of those uh streaming sites and
you'll be able to participate you can
type your bible question right in the
comment section if you're on facebook
and we'll try to answer as many of these
bible questions of course you can call
in with your bible question and the
number to call is
that's 1-800-463-7297
and that that'll get your call on the
air let's start with the word of prayer
dear father once again we are so
grateful that we have this time to be
able to just open up your word and study
the most
important book in the world studying the
most wonderful topic in the world that
is your grace and so we ask your
blessing upon this program be with those
who are listening and watching and guide
us lord into a clearer understanding
what the bible says we ask this in jesus
name amen amen well we're ready for the
phone lines pastor doug our first caller
that we have is a peyton listening from
virginia peyton welcome to the program
yes sir um my question was in regards to
acts um chapter 20 and it started in
verse 7
and i was listening to the radio the
other day and there was a pastor who
came on
and he was referencing this section of
scripture
as a reason uh why would that um we
should gather on sunday that it put an
emphasis on uh the apostles gathering on
sunday and that we should too
and uh with the utmost respect after
reading through it i i couldn't really
take that away from it so i was just
asking is this patch
is this passage of scripture and i read
through the end of the chapter uh
putting an emphasis on you know uh
scattering on sunday or the first day of
the week it says
um and if not is there any other place
in the bible that maybe not calls it the
sabbath day but has an emphasis on us
gathering on the first day of the week
well let me read this for our friends
that are listening and this is found in
acts 20 and i'll start with verse 7.
now on the first day of the week when
the disciples came together to break
bread now let's stop right there people
say there you have it first day of the
week that's what we typically call
sunday it's the day that jesus rose the
disciples came together and some will
argue well they came together to break
bread that means that this was a
communion service
and that it was now the new sabbath day
of course there's nothing in the passage
here that tells us those things that's a
tremendous assumption the word breaking
bread the phrase breaking bread says the
disciples broke bread from house to
house daily so to say that that means it
was a new holy day you can't really
support that it says they broke bread
from house of house daily in acts
chapter 2.
now why is this story being told let's
keep reading now on the first day of the
week when the disciples came together to
break bread why paul ready to depart the
next day
he spoke to them and continued his
message until midnight so they're
gathering
the evening of the first day is what we
call saturday night because the days for
in the in the
bible a day begins and ends at sundown
and so here you've got saturday night
they've spent the sabbath together
they gather together again for a
saturday evening meeting that's
in the jews mind that's the first day of
the week
and they're gathering because paul's
leaving the next day
well if the next day is sunday holiday
why would he begin a journey it's not a
day of rest if he does that
he speaks to them and he continues his
message till midnight
and there's many upper rooms where they
were gathered and a young boy named
uticus falls from the window
three stories up
and it looks like he's dead it says he's
taken up dead paul goes down prays over
him he comes back to life the story is
here not to establish a new sabbath the
story is telling the miracle of paul
resurrecting uticus
and so when people say this is evidence
that god changed one of the ten
commandments
that would be a very flimsy support
scripture to try and say that because
it's not it's not even telling us that
it all began on what we would call
sunday it
starts at saturday night
uh on the first day of the week begins
at sundown well i hope that made sense
peyton i appreciate your question and
you know the other verse that people
typically use as they go to first
corinthians 13
paul said that on the first of the week
they should
set aside some special money talking
about at home
so there are no offerings when he comes
he was taking an offering to jerusalem
and those are the two principal verses
people to talk about and they say this
is proof that there was a new sabbath
that was changed but they can't find a
command anywhere nope not in the new
testament or in the old testament you
know we do have a book it's called the
last day of history and it deals with
this passage as well as some others that
people often get confused about but it's
very clear if you look at what the bible
says all the way from genesis all the
way through to revelation it talks about
a day that god has set aside a day of
worship and gathering holy convocation
is the word that's used we'll be happy
to send this to anyone who asked again
just ask for the study guide is called
the last day of history and the number
to call for that is
800-835-6747 it's 800-835-6747
next quarter that we have is lucas
listening in tennessee lucas welcome to
the program
so my question
pertains to the um to marriage in the
old testament
i understand it was very common practice
for people to have multiple wives
and um it's been
described as
a time of ignorance that god winked at
but
i've been
studying the old testament more lately
i've been reading the book of joshua and
stuff
from my old testament studies class and
it appears as though
god seemed to
be in very direct contact with this
people during this time
and so my question is
is why didn't god directly
let people know that hey
i don't want you to have multiple lives
i don't want you to have concubines
instead of just
winking over it
yeah well and you can also add to that
i'm not trying to complicate the
question it's pretty clear that they had
slaves
and uh you know i i don't believe the
lord supports slavery but slavery was
ubiquitous in bible times you know just
even all the way through the time of
christ they had slaves all over the
roman empire
but you know the the times were so
barbaric
that god kind of gave them the light
they could handle one more thing to
consider
they actually did have a jewish law
that if a man's brother got married and
before they could have children
if he died he was to take his brother's
wife into his family and treat her like
a second wife
now the reason for that was
a lot of men died out in battle
you can read a passage in isaiah chapter
7 no isaiah chapter 4 verse 1
and it says in that day seven women will
take hold of one man
saying we'll eat our own bread we'll
wear our own apparel only let us be
called by your name to take away our
reproach
because so many men had died off in
battle that there were seven women for
every man they've got this problem in
china right now where so many uh girls
is actually the opposite so many girls
were aborted when they had uh
optional or you know selective abortions
that they got like uh you know three
quarters more men than they do women
um so to make sure that these women they
had no social security that they were
not left destitute and widows with no
children he would take them into his
home and raise up children to him first
you know jacob did that when he married
rachel and leah
it always brought hardik in the family
and if you want to know what god's
original plan was you go to the garden
of eden god made one woman
for adam
and
one man for eve
and that's god's plan
and you see it reproduced in the new
testament church there's no example of
people having
more than one wife at a time in the
jewish community in christ time
all right well thanks for your call
lucas next quarter that we have is jess
listening from um
washington jess welcome to the program
yeah um i was just curious i was
studying
the children of israel being in egypt
for 400 years
and i
happened to decide i'm going to find out
how many days they were there so i added
up 360 times 400
and i came up with 144 000
and i thought that was pretty
interesting i was thinking
maybe that was a key or
one of the things that could be pointing
to who the 144 000 are it's those that
would um
go through the seven last plagues of
course unscathed because they did come
out after seven live plays that first
three affected them
you know i just i love doing this
program because i just learned something
from you i've never thought about that
that's great very interesting that those
uh 400 times 360 is 100 and is that
right 144 000. that would make sense
we're trusting your math
i've added it up about 30 times to make
sure yeah i believe you i'm do it in my
head right now and it seems like it
would work you know the interesting
thing about that is uh pasadena you've
got you've got those in egypt they go
through the plagues and then they are
delivered and taken to the promised land
at the end of time in revelation follow
the law yeah they keep the law of god
you got the hundred and forty four
thousand who and everywhere they went
they had to follow after the ark of the
covenant yeah they followed the ark and
they went through the sanctuary services
they lived through that
well i'm going to add that to my notes
in my sermon on 144 000. i'd never i'd
never done that before that that's
wonderful
now uh you by the way for our friends
that are listening the verse where it
says that the children of israel would
be 400 years is in genesis chapter 15
verse is it verse
13 yeah 400 years yeah
so for those who are wondering where
that comes from and i should add
that that time begins while abraham is
still alive the time does not begin when
jacob goes down they are only physically
in egypt for about 200 years
when you start adding up the genealogies
it's talking about when the persecution
of ishmael against isaac began
it's 400 years until the exodus maybe
just one more thing to add if you want
to do the math and you take the 400
years
times the number of days remember the
hebrew year has three hundred and sixty
days it's not three hundred and sixty
lunar calendar they did not use 365.
and that's good very well very good jess
i sure appreciate that that's
fascinating yeah a great point add that
note to my study well thank you jess
next quality we have is julian listening
from maryland julian welcome to the
program hello pastors hi thanks for
calling thank you
hey
so i actually have two questions is that
okay well let's take them one at a time
and see how long it takes
okay
so i read that god speaks to prophets in
three different ways through visions
dreams or face to face
when it says face to face is it
literally face to face like with god
being in your face
god the son
has appeared to prophets face to face of
course you know jesus appeared to paul
no man have seen the father and i'm
trying to remember the passage i think
john wrote that no man has seen the
father so god the father no man is seen
face to face
even moses when god said i'll show you
my glory he says no man can look at my
face and live so i'll put you in a cleft
of a rock i'll pass by
you'll see my glory from behind
so when it says they saw god it's
talking about god the son that's uh john
chapter 1 verse 18. thank you now one
prophet that does come to mind is moses
god said talking about moses it says
i'll communicate to the prophets through
dreams or revision but my servant moses
i speak to him face to face and of
course this is christ communicating with
moses
uh there's not too many and abraham yeah
god spoke to abraham there's not too
many prophets even prophets in the bible
where god spoke face to face we have a
few examples most of them were through
dreams and visions right
we believe that was uh
the lord that spoke to uh joshua that's
the kind of yeah
take your shoes off yeah
so
uh i hope that helps a little bit julian
and we appreciate it now do we have time
for hey let's see do you have a quick
second one second question
yeah do i have to be a prophet for god
to communicate with me in that way
no
uh that's that's actually a valid
question uh you know there are people in
the bible the lord might communicate you
with you in a direct way it doesn't mean
that you're a full-time prophet an
example would be
when the lord appeared to the parents of
samson
and he had a particular one-time message
for him i guess he met with him twice
and well he met with a woman twice the
man once
um so you know the lord may at any time
at his discretion you know meet with
someone one time
but
it doesn't mean you're a full-time
profit they were not profits
all right thanks nicole the next caller
that we have is april listening in
florida april welcome to the program
um so my question is
i remember one night you were preaching
by the way i like your backflips when
you were um preaching in michigan oh
it's been a while since i did one but
um so i remember one night you were
talking about how you were preaching the
church and
you mentioned that angels was around you
but there was probably demons around too
and that we that they didn't like what
you were preaching but we live in a
second dimension and they live in a
third dimension and so we can't see them
so my question is
do they conflict with each other and we
just can't see it
yes um you do have that verse in
revelation chapter 12 where it says
there was war in heaven michael and his
angels fought with the dragon and the
dragon and his angels fought so here
you've got good angels and bad angels at
war and i'm sure it not only happened
there in heaven but when um
where there's a verse where it talks
about michael and the prince of persia
in daniel 10 what are you looking
something up here i was just looking at
the verse you met you quoted in
revelation chapter 12 verse 7 where it
talks about war in heaven between
michael and these angels and the dragon
and these angels and the dragon lost
satan lost the war and he was thrown out
of heaven so they didn't leave willingly
there must have been some kind of actual
pushing them out of heaven bible says
the angel of the lord encamps round
about those who fear him and delivers
them and then uh the devil said you've
stationed a hedge about job that you
were protecting job with a hedge we
believe that's a hedge of angels and so
satan's angels are trying to
you know overcome god's angels and break
through so to speak so i do believe
there are spiritual battles paul said we
don't wrestle against flesh and blood
but against principalities and powers
and spiritual rulers of darkness and
high places that's ephesians chapter 6.
so
i think if our eyes could be opened and
the veil removed from it's probably not
the third dimension it's the fourth or
fifth
fifth dimension was a singing group too
but you would see angels battling um and
you know god is always sending angels to
guard and protect us
sometimes the evil angels are trying to
get through and the way i think that uh
they lose is by
our prayers
and the prayers and intercession of
others
you know we have a
dvd pastor there's actually video now
it's available on youtube it's called
cosby conflict and it really kind of
pulls back the veil and you can it tells
the story of this war in heaven and then
how the devil came to the earth and
tempted adam and eve and yes there is a
real battle taking place around us we
can't see it but it's real
forces of good against the forces of
evil
thank you for your call april we've got
devion listening from
charlotte south carolina davion welcome
hi
um
i'm eight years old and
i just heard this word um from a movie
that me and my father was watching
and
i just wanted to ask you it okay um
why did jesus tell mary that she
couldn't hold on to him because he did
not ascend to the father yet
all right good question this is in the
gospel of john chapter 20 i believe
and it's after the resurrection
and
peter and john have seen the empty tomb
and they leave and mary stays there
she's by herself now and she's crying
christ appears to her first she thinks
he's the gardener then he says mary and
she recognizes him she throws herself at
his feet to grab his feet to worship him
and he says do not if you look in the
king james says do not touch me and that
word is not the best translation he says
do not cling to me or hold on to me
because i'm not yet ascended to my
father
he's basically saying look i can't stay
and visit with you right now mary used
to love to sit at jesus feet and listen
to him teach the word he said i don't
have time for that now i must ascend to
heaven i've just risen from the dead
you're the first one i'm appearing to
i'm going to go to heaven and i'm going
to
present myself before the father and
hear that my sacrifice was successful on
behalf of mankind
and he then came down again later that
evening he met with the disciples in the
upper room he also met with peter that
day and it says that when they saw him
he said all hail then they worshipped
him they talked to him he said touch my
side touch my hands
and he had no problem with him touching
him he just said to mary you can't i
can't stay you can't cling to me now
because i need to ascend
yeah you know you look at the original
word in the greek past that it carries
the idea of of holding back or or
clinging to someone jesus
detaining my mission is not is not
complete yet i need to go
good question thank you for calling
we've got marquise listening from
indianapolis indiana marquise welcome to
the program
and good evening pastor ross and pastor
doug my question comes from uh
first kings chapter 19 verse 11-13
and basically i was just trying to see
why did the arthur use the strong wind
the earthquake and the fire if the lord
wasn't in it
yeah this is when elijah flees from
jezebel he ends up at mount sinai
and
then god gives him this sign he's kind
of teaching him with a lesson
and it says that there's a
an earthquake then there's a fire
there's a powerful wind that can rent
the rocks
and it says god was not in those things
that's very interesting because
you know whenever there is a terrible
fire or earthquake or a hurricane we say
it's an act of god
and god is telling us that you know i
i'm not always in those things but then
it says there's a still small voice
and what it's doing is in this story god
is contrasting these earth-shaking
events and he says sometimes god speaks
through a still small voice
god had been guiding elijah for three
and a half years and everywhere god led
him he took care of him he was by a
brook he stayed with a widow on mount
carmel
god never told him through the holy
spirit that still small voice to run to
mount sinai he never said run from
jezebel
and god has said why are you here i
didn't tell you to come here
and so he was listening to the fear
you know the fire and the and the wind
and the earthquake and god is saying you
know i'll speak to you through the holy
spirit you don't need to
look at the signs of the weather or some
disaster
to hear my voice
you know pastor i just said that i think
sometimes we're we wanting a big sign
we're wanting something miraculous just
to help confirm that we're doing what
god wants us to do
but here we find in the story god is
reminding us that he speaks to us
through the holy spirit if we honestly
are seeking to do his will
through that still small voice through
his word we don't always have to have a
miracle of these big signs we could just
trust in
the promise that god will lead us if we
are willing to do his will that's right
so hey thank you very much marquis i
appreciate your question
and we got a minute 46 i don't know that
may not be time for uh another one we're
we're coming back with more bible
questions in just a minute friends but
we see the break is creeping up on us
and we want to remind you
that
amazing facts has
an abundance of bible study resources at
our mothership website that's very
simply amazingfacts.org
if you even google amazing facts you'll
see they're amazing facts ministry
amazing facts international and there
you've got bible studies you can enter
in the bible study course
you can go to one of our many other
websites we've got to websites that deal
with specific doctrines in great detail
we also have an amazing facts youtube
channel that has a library of sermons
that is growing every week
and as well as um our facebook accounts
and
by the way so someone has to wants to
send us an internet question pastor ross
what is the ad yeah just simply bal
questions at amazingfacts.org
now of course we're not finished yet we
got a whole half an hour of programs
still ahead we're just taking a break
but you can post your question there at
bal questions at amazingfacts.org
and we'll try to answer as many of those
questions at the end of the program
we'll be right back stay tuned
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
does your heart burn for a better
purpose
do you yearn to do more with your faith
do you desire to be a powerful witness a
blaze for jesus christ
where do you start make your first step
at afco the amazing fact center of
evangelism here at afco i've learned so
many things and my spiritual growth has
just skyrocketed afco has distilled 50
years of amazing facts evangelistic
expertise into a dynamic professional
and educational experience that
transforms the nervous christian into a
prepared and bold witness
afco is really about learning while
doing it's a one-of-a-kind experience
for those who are serious about entering
gospel ministry and those who simply
want to make an impact in their local
churches and communities go to afco.org
today and explore this life-changing
program
afco equipping soul winners setting the
world a blaze for god
go into all the world and preach the
gospel to every creature
through radio television print
evangelistic events and the internet
amazing facts international is heeding
the call of jesus to go into all the
world
millions of individuals in over 150
countries have been blessed by the word
of god amazing facts has spawned new
spheres of influence in india africa
china and indonesia with each new
country come hundreds of translated
booklets study guides and video
presentations produced in each region
for the people of that region armed with
these precious truths gospel workers are
empowered to spread bright rays of light
on every path they travel
please visit
reachtheworld.amazingfacts.org
to learn more about amazing facts
international and how you can
participate in this exciting soul
winning ministry that website again is
reachtheworld.amazingfacts.org
thank you for your support
[Music]
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
bible related questions on the air
please call us next sunday between 7 p.m
and 8 p.m pacific time
to receive any of the bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program call
800-835-6747
once again that's 800-835
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live we're about to move into
the last 28 minutes of bible answers and
if you'd like to call in with a question
it's 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
we're also broadcasting if you want to
see the video on af tv that's the
amazing facts television channel af tv
and we want to thank our friends in
arizona for the good news network has
begun broadcasting amazing facts the
video as well
and of course the radio broadcast around
the country i am doug batchelor my name
is john ross and we've got e frank that
he's listening from new york e frank
welcome to the program you on the air
yes uh good uh evening pastor doug and
pastor ross
i would just like to ask this question
that's always been
on my mind for several uh decades you
know i've been hearing things about
miracles
in the old testament jesus did many
miracles and performed them according to
god's will
but he never explained anything that was
scientific or the reasons in general why
he conducted the miracles he did
my question for
both of you pastors
is uh in general
i would just like to ask you this
are there still uh ways and methods
where uh there are
individuals who are on earth
that they are still conducting a
miracles like jesus did at the time a
period that he did as the son of god
because
i noticed so many
books that i and
literary articles that indicate that uh
there are still people on earth who
claim to do attributable acts of christ
is so uh my question is are there
individuals who are doing the same thing
yeah oh well i do believe that there are
miracles i think miracles come as a
result of answered prayer you know god
pray i believe the lord has performed
miracles and when you say miracle what
do you mean you mean something that is
extraordinarily above and beyond and out
of what would appear to be natural
and
when you read about miracle healings i
know people pastor ross and i have
prayed for people we're not we don't
claim to have a healing ministry
that you know bible says if you have
certain serious illness you might call
for the pastors to come and pray and
maybe even anoint with oil and we've
known people that had uh you know
serious cancer diagnosis that were
healed and then no trace anymore
sometimes the lord performs those
miracles
through medical intervention
those kind of miracles you see in
you know the book of exodus where
the
sea is parting and
or it's turning to blood and the hail
and the fire
i think you're going to see those again
in the last days according to revelation
so miracles and the power and influence
of miracles seems to come in waves
but
you know jesus said that he gave his
disciples power
um to
pray and to perform certain miracles and
when the church is full of the holy
spirit uh different times in history
we've seen some extraordinary things
happen
of course the bible does warn us at the
same time it says beware of false
prophets that show signs and wonders
don't be deceived so you're going to
have the genuine especially in the last
days but there's also going to be a lot
of counterfeit and so how do you know
the difference well the bible says by
their fruits you shall know them it
seems pastor that we've seen as an
insurgent or just
just more and more people claiming to be
able to do miracles and
if you look at what they are teaching
and you look at their lives you realize
it's not really in harmony with the
principles of the bible yeah so
somebody's making merchandise or making
money claiming to be able to heal others
and
unfortunately there's a lot of fraud and
uh people aren't really being healed
yeah for every true prophet there's
probably a hundred false ones yep that's
running to mount carmel yeah there you
go
all right great question thank you frank
we got bill listening texas bill welcome
to bible answers live
hi i'm a repeat uh caller and here's my
question
since adam lived 930 years according to
genesis 5 5
and god warned adam and eve for in the
day you eat of the tree of knowledge's
fruit that you shall surely die
according to genesis 2
15-17 wasn't god telling them
that they would eat from it
and die less than a thousand years since
with the lord one day is a thousand
years according to second peter 3 8.
all right yeah good question
um you know in the
in the phrase where god says in the day
you eat thereof you will surely die
in the hebrew it reads in dying you will
die in other words a dying process would
begin in the day that you eat thereof
they certainly did go through a
spiritual death that day their garments
of glory disappeared and they discovered
their nakedness
and
there was shame uh they could no longer
eat from the tree of life and the
absence of life means death
and so in a sense a death sentence began
that day
but they no man
except enoch who was taken to heaven uh
all the other people died within that
first millennium or that first thousand
years so they did die in that first day
so in that sense you're correct
that
a day being as a thousand years with the
lord
adam died 930 years and we doesn't give
the day of
uh the lifespan of eve but we're
assuming that she also died
within that millennium
thank you bill thank you we've got
george listening from maryland george
welcome to the program
i've been having struggles with
tithes uh because i've been giving it
and above and beyond but as i got older
and i got disabled
i have not been able to
work because of my disability both
mental and physical
and
because of that i have not not been able
to give tithes
and
on social security i have been puzzled
because i know what the scripture says
about time about the gross income
that you uh
you know gather i know about methuselah
i you know i know about
all that is taught about ties except
when i've gotten to the age now where
i'm a senior
uh and i'm not working and strictly
living on social security i have stopped
giving ties
because of the fact is
it's not income right it's simply money
given from the federal government
through social security for the us
treasury let me listen
with that for the hardest time
and i felt bad and i felt like well
let's talk about it
he just left me
okay
let's talk about that george yeah um
when to keep in mind now when a person
pays social security uh if you're
receiving social security i i just saw
this week that you know if and when i
retire what my social security income
will be and it won't be that much
but if when you're working i paid into
it so i've already you know if i'm
paying tithe the years i'm getting a
check and they're deducting social
security
you're basically paying into that
and um
uh if you're paying tithe on it when you
first get your paycheck and you're
paying on the gross
then
in a sense you have paid tithe on the
social security at that point so it
depends on what you did in those years
when you were receiving your paycheck
if you never paid tithe on your social
security social security is you know
just like an expense like anything else
you pay into a fund you get it back when
you retire
um
well then you you technically would owe
it
but um you know i don't believe god
wants you to be destitute but he says
test him
and he says see if he doesn't open for
you the windows of heaven
so i'd say you know be faithful
as you can and do what you can god never
asks us to do what we can't do but he
wants us to have faith and obey his word
so you'd have to answer the question
george about what happened during the
years when you were working and you were
earning a check were you paying tithe on
those um
deductions
we do have a study guide talking about
the subject it's called in god we trust
and you might have some further
questions about that we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number to call for that is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for the
amazing facts study guide it's called in
god we trust and it's just jam packed
with scripture some wonderful principles
and you'll be blessed by reading that
next caller that we have is kenny
listening from south carolina kenny
welcome to the program
how are you doing thank you for taking
my call yeah thanks for coming this
falls in
chapter 21 of revelations and also
galatians 4 26
the bride of christ
i become a sabbath keeper
back in 2004
and god has opened my eyes
to the to the word of god
and some of the things that i see
i try to explain to people what he has
put on me
and they i don't know if they try to
confuse me or try to get me to pull back
from that but i'm like
the truth of it that i'm feeling in my
spirit i can't let go of it where the
bride of christ in revelations 21 it
talks about where john
uh was
chapter 21 verse 2. and now john saw the
holy city come down from heaven prepared
as a bride adorned her husband
in galatians it talks about
uh new jerusalem is a mother of us all
free and bonding mother of assault right
so
if you
you look at the spiritual analogy there
in ephesians it says husbands love your
wives
as christ loved the church
and gave himself for her so the analogy
of the church
and we are the church you know bible
says we're living stones in this temple
being the bride of christ you find
actually new and old testament
when the church was being unfaithful god
said that his bride his
wife was
playing a harlot
and he uses the analogy of marriage many
times so
yeah so there's no question it uses the
picture of the new jerusalem where the
church is going to live it's really
talking about the church not it's not
the buildings are the bride of christ it
means the people that live in that new
jerusalem are his bride and you know if
you're finding the bible then in the old
testament you've got two cities you've
got babylon representing those who are
opposed to the truth and opposed to god
a persecuting power then you have
jerusalem which represents god's people
so in revelation 21 where it's talking
about the lamb's wife and then it
describes the new jerusalem the new
jerusalem is a symbol of god's people
it's the home of the redeemed
and it's the kingdom the capital of the
kingdom that christ receives so you know
jesus isn't interested in a building per
se even if it's made with gold i mean
there's nothing god cannot do but he is
interested in people he wants to save
people so when the new jerusalem is
populated with the redeemed
that's the bride of christ amen
all right thanks for your call
appreciate it we've got della who is
listening from california della welcome
to the program
hi thank you for taking my call
my question is what does the bible teach
to us about women serving in the
ministry can women be deaconesses and
elders and pastors
well you you mentioned a few different
offices there first let's establish that
god gives spiritual gifts to everybody
that he wants us to use in ministry now
ministry is kind of a comprehensive term
that means in
serving the lord in ministering
um the roles uh and the word deacon it
means servant and so you've got men and
women that serve as deacons and i think
there's an example of deaconess or a
female deacon in the bible you do not
see an example in the bible of a woman
serving in the capacity
of a priest apostle or pastor
and you know pastor and elder were
interchangeable they call him bishop
pastor elder it just meant the shepherd
of the church though
that was uh typically
it's a male role
and the
you know the bible tells us that
husbands are to be the servant leaders
protecting their families and the church
is really a family so it's an extension
of that same arrangement
through the bible it was always the
patriarch the father that offered
sacrifice you have no example of a woman
offering sacrifice in the bible
so
we stick with the word and we believe
that yes you know women can serve in
teaching the word and doing evangelism
and doing bible studies in all kinds of
ministry
uh a lot of the greatest missionaries
were women i just got done reading about
amy carmichael
and there's so many others that went to
the mission field and established a
great work and did a great ministry
but you do not see women serving in
those three capacities of
um you know priest
um
we do have women prophets i was gonna i
was gonna mention that actually if you
look at the lineup of the spiritual
gifts you've got pastors and evangelists
but right at the top of the list you've
got apostles and you've got prophets and
we have examples in the old testament
and the new testament of woman prophets
doing a very important work we even have
an example of a woman participating in
the judging of when israel was still
governed by judges and she would comment
but she was also a prophet
so um there are some very significant
roles for women especially in ministry
and even in the church today some
important roles that women have but like
you say pastor day if we're going to
follow the biblical guidelines that's
given another one is if you look at the
guidelines given in scripture for an
elder or a bishop
or a past in the church one of the
characteristics he needs to be a good
husband and provide for his family
and he needs to have a good reputation
in the community so i mean just the
principles that's given makes it pretty
clear that there is a distinction
yeah it's hard for a woman to be a
husband of one wife that's right unless
you're in california yeah
so be careful now yeah i to be careful
what i say
you know we do have a book it's called
god's role for women in ministry and
we'll be happy to send this out to
anyone who calls and asks the number to
call is 800-835-6747
and again you can ask for the book it's
called god's role for women in ministry
thank you for your call good question
we've got uh let's see darling darlene
he's listening in north carolina darlene
you're on the air
hi how are you thanks for taking my call
thank you um i just have a very puzzling
question i'd like to ask pastor doug
um
here on earth you know we get tempted or
influenced with things like jealousy
pride and greed
and we know that that comes from satan
and we can pray through it and god will
give us help
but my question is when
lucifer was in heaven and he was created
perfect and he was in a perfect
environment
who influenced him
before the before there was a satan
to uh you know try to to be jealous of
god and want to be like him and prideful
right
yeah so we often if we're doing
something selfish we say well the devil
tempted me so who tempted the devil
who who what was the source of that
first temptation
the bible speaks in
pastor russell another reference but the
bible speaks of the mystery of iniquity
there are mystery two mysteries in the
bible you've got the mystery of
godliness you get the mystery of
iniquity
and um
it's a mystery why lucifer began to
think selfish proud thoughts but it
germinated in his own heart
and uh you know everyone says well i
caught the cold from this person well
where'd the first person catch the first
cold from
you know you could those kind of
mysteries you could keep asking
um
so
uh lucifer
of his own volition he saw jesus
receiving the adoration of the angels
and he had the thought within himself
why am i not god
why don't i have that power why don't i
get that worship and
instead of rejecting that thought as he
should have he embraced it and he kept
nurturing that thought until it festered
and it grew in his own mind until he
just became con consumed with
selfishness instead of love so he really
drowned the love of god in his own heart
talking about the mystery of iniquity
pastor act second thessalonians chapter
two verse seven
that talks about that and we have a i
just wanted to mention to uh darlene we
do have
a
video you can probably watch it free
online you can order it from amazing
facts it's called cosmic conflict tell
us about the fall of lucifer and how
that all began
thank you for your call we've got robert
listening in washington robert welcome
to the program
good evening pastor ross and pastor doug
regarding first corinthians 15 29
uh it seems like uh paul is encouraging
um the believers to to be baptized to
the dead by
by the
by the wording of first corinthians 15
29 yes
i know paul is not encouraging being
baptized for the dead because that i'm
saying yes i understand what you're
saying
that would be um
really anathema to everything else the
bible teaches the bible says that it's
appointed unto man once to die after
that the judgment it's not after you die
then you get baptized or someone gets
baptized in your behalf
it says the righteousness of the
righteous will be upon him and the
wickedness of the wicked each man pays
for his own sin and is rewarded for his
own good works we're not saved by good
works but the bible says we're rewarded
according to our work so the idea that
you could get baptized for someone else
that's been dead and buried long gone
bible definitely does not teach that
what does this first mean let me read it
to our friends who are listening this is
a place where if the punctuation is not
in the right spot
it gets you confused there was no
punctuation in the greek when paul wrote
this that was added by translators later
sometimes they got it right sometimes
they got it wrong this is a place where
i think they got it very wrong and it's
caused some confusion here's the verse
otherwise what will they do who are
baptized for the dead if the dead do not
rise at all
why then are they baptized for the dead
all right that's the verse now the way i
read it it sounds like why are they
baptized for the dead if the dead don't
rise at all now let's read it with the
appropriate punctuation i'll try and put
the right emphasis
on the right syllables here
otherwise what will they do who are
baptized comma
for the dead if the dead rise not at all
why then are they baptized
comma for the dead question mark paul is
saying those who are baptized why are
they getting baptized period for if the
dead don't rise at all why then are they
being baptized and he asks a rhetorical
question are they being baptized for the
dead
he's actually saying you shouldn't be
baptized for the dead
he said if you don't believe in baptism
why are you even doing it
well even more important i think he's
emphasized if you don't believe in the
resurrection that's really the context
of the whole chapter he says you know if
somebody's baptized and of course they
were at the time they were a group of
people known as the sadducees they
didn't believe in the resurrection from
the dead you've got the pharisees they
did believe in the resurrection but the
sadducees in a large group
they said this is it when you die it's
the end paul's saying well if there's no
resurrection then what's the point of
being baptized you know what about all
of those who have died and were baptized
what's going to happen to them so i
think that's the point that he's trying
to emphasize
hope that helps a little bit and we
thank you for your for your question br
robert yeah we have joan listening from
anchorage alaska joan welcome to the
program
well thank you and uh good evening
pastors
i have a problem
uh concerning the star
that led the wise men
to where jesus was born and that the
star first led them
to jerusalem where herod was there that
wanted to kill jesus
and yet
when they got there to jesus and and and
they had a dream
and the dream told them to go another
way home
why didn't that star then bring them to
the way that they were going home
another way instead of taking that right
straight to herod it almost seems to me
like satan was
shoving that star over to jerusalem
okay i think
yeah i think i understand what you're
asking uh why did the star not lead him
just right to the house the first time
uh well first of all when you know when
a star is in the sky
it's kind of hard maybe to tell exactly
where you are when you're right under it
and
they were led i think one reason god led
him into jerusalem you notice it says
that all jerusalem was a stir
when they said where is he born of the
king of the jews i think the lord wanted
that to happen the lord did not want
herod to do what he did to the babies in
bethlehem the lord wanted jerusalem to
know that gentiles were coming
looking for the birth of the messiah why
weren't god's people looking for the
birth of the messiah
and so that question was supposed to
rouse them to say yes help us find him
but the people didn't follow the wise
men to bethlehem they didn't believe
just some shepherds and some foreign
wise men why didn't that star guide them
back the other way well the star was to
guide them to the destination to christ
which it did
and at that point the sign disappeared
they knew how to get home they were just
told to take a southern route instead of
the northern route
and so they didn't need a star that was
just to avoid detection you know what's
interesting about that story pastor
you've got herod going to the scribes
and he asked them well where is the
messiah or the king supposed to be born
and they the ones that say he's going to
be born in bethlehem and the only ones
who actually go to bethlehem to find the
christ
are the wise men and the soldiers and
the soldiers that eventually came that's
right but why didn't why didn't the
scribes go you know why did the
religious leaders go why didn't all of
jerusalem go they had an opportunity i
think that's the point god gave his
people the jews an opportunity to
welcome the redeemer great point and yet
they they rejected that yeah it's
unfortunate yesterday
all right thanks for your call great
question we've got let's see tom from uh
tom from west virginia that's wv isn't
it yep all right one minute tom can we
do it well we probably can uh i'm
looking at revelation 14 verse 11
and the smoke of their torment ascendeth
up forever and ever and they have no
rest day nor night
who worship the beast and his image and
whosoever receiveth the mark of his name
i was wondering about uh in the context
of the lord always covering himself in
smoke like when he was leading the
hebrews through the wilderness
when he filled the temple with smoke
when solomon dedicated it
and uh also in uh revelation
15 at the the last
verse it mentions the temple was filled
with smoke
uh i wanted to ask you guys what you
think about because i don't know the
hebrew or the greek rendering rather all
right i i don't think the smoke it's
talking about in revelation 14 is
talking about the smoke of god's
shekinah glory as it went up from mount
sinai i believe there it's talking more
about the smoke that went up from sodom
it says when sodom and gomor were
destroyed it was like the smoke of a
furnace that is a fire of destruction
instead of it being the fire or smoke of
god's glory that you might see in um
there at the end of revelation
but hopefully that helps a little bit
and you know if we didn't give you a
complete answer please call back and
give us another chance robert
listening friends we're so thankful that
you've tuned in the bible answers live
this evening do not go very far away
we're going to be signing off in just a
moment from our um
our satellite radio listeners
but we're going to stay and do some
rapid fire bible questions we're going
to see how many bible questions we can
get through in about two minutes and i
want to remind everyone that's listening
that
you can be listening to bible answers
live all the time
just by going to the website you can
watch amazing facts programming 24 hours
a day if you have a roku
we're on channel there and also on
amazing facts tv via the internet and so
we hope that you'll continue to listen
to watch stay connected with and pray
for the ministry
god bless and we'll be back in a moment
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
bible even better than before bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts international a faith-based
ministry located in granite bay
california
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live we have about two minutes
left in the program and we've got a
number of bible questions that have been
emailed in and so past today we're going
to try and cover as many of these
questions as we can so here's question
number one are christians supposed to
follow the mosaic law
well when you see the mosaic law you if
you're including the ten commandments
certainly we're supposed to keep the ten
commandments if you're talking about the
ceremonial laws related to the sanctuary
its services sacrificing lambs
circumcision those things are all nailed
to the cross they were fulfilled in
christ there are good practical social
laws and health laws that are still
applicable today
that a matter of fact many countries our
laws are based on the laws of moses but
ceremonial ordinances no
okay question number two it says how do
you know that you have the holy spirit
the bible tells us that the way that you
know if a tree
is what the type of a tree is is by the
fruit and you read in galatians chapter
that it is by the fruits of the spirit
jesus said in matthew i believe it's
chapter 5 you'll know them by their
fruits
and so look at the fruits in the life
okay question number three we've got
matthew and mark both speak about jesus
saying that this generation will not
pass away until he returns what does
this mean
well they're asking him three questions
in mark 13 and matthew 24 they're asking
when will these things be meaning the
destruction of jerusalem where there's
not one stone left upon another what
will be the sign of your coming in the
end of the world jesus is explaining
that the destruction of jerusalem this
generation and bible generation is 40
years would not pass away until those
things were fulfilled he made that
statement in approximately 30 a.d in 70
a.d 40 years later the temple was
destroyed and that those prophecies were
fulfilled
okay another question we have it says
is probation closed yet for the world
well let's hope not once probation
closes that means that the loss can no
longer be saved
but there's nothing that i've seen or
read that's led me to believe we should
cease proclaiming the good news when the
seven last plagues begin to fall and the
waters and oceans turn to blood that'll
probably mean probation is closed that
hasn't happened yet
all right last question that we have
pastor dug in our last 30 seconds
what about using unclean animals not to
eat but for medicinal uses is that okay
and i'm thinking for example a pig's
heart
or not a heart but a valve a valve yeah
you know sometimes there are there's
hardware in some animals have used to
save people's lives and that's a very
interesting question
i would probably want that as preferred
to dying that'd be healthier god bless
friends we've enjoyed our time together
and look forward to your tuning in next
week